[Música]
ella no pudo graduarse de la primaria me
ha inspirado más que nada que sigue
estudiando que yo siga siga y siga
adelante para que yo no tenga que vivir
lo que ella vivió
[Música]
lo que sí muchísimo me ayudó fue en
matemáticas yo casi no soy muy bueno y
gracias a esta plataforma ha probado una
gran diferencia empecé a ver cosas que
no entendía descalificaciones no así
subieron demasiadas
[Música]
he entrado mucho más confianza tanto en
mí mismo en responder problemas lo que
yo quiero estudiar ingeniería en
informática son códigos binarios
matemáticas cálculo
[Música]
y yo quiero seguir estudiando para sacar
a la familia para toda la mía y como a
mis papás también quiero darle el
ejemplo a mis hermanos ya que si se
puede sí se puede superen si a ustedes
mismos se pueden ser sus límites